hello I'm a nostalgia critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well
every year I always do some sort of
special Halloween episode but this year
fucking I'm doing the entire month so
get ready kids all through October
you're going to experience nostalgia
weeds and what better way to start off
this terrifying month in with a
terrifying movie not really scary just
terrifying
let's take a look at Ernest scared
stupid
let's service movie to be shown in
theaters and pi God you can see why
Ernest scared stupid certainly lives up
to its title
it has Ernest it's stupid and it's scary
in its own right and that the idea
sitting through this ass testicle of a
movie scares the living shit out of me
so let the bitching hour commence this
is Ernest scared stupid so the client
opened with Ernest played again by jim
Varney as he reacts to cheesy scary
movies that are probably more
entertaining than this cheesy scary
movie
wait a minute well the fuck's that guy
what did one other stagehand save the
directors life so he promised him a
pointless one second in a movie doesn't
even make sense I mean if I for one
second changed into somebody else would
it add up no no one's as the credits
continue we see that the movie was
written by John cherry and coke Sam's so
yes this movie was officially written by
Jerry cook
that's how strange an experience were in
for folks when a movie written by a soda
fasten your seat belts so we open with a
girl being chased by the evil dead
monster as if finally quarters are up
against a tree
Oh points take it off for smiling
but the monster is captured and buried
under an oak tree because maybe he makes
good fertilizer as we cut two years
later worker in his pee world now has a
job as a garbage truck driver hey this
will be my have a happy ending after all
I was wondering why the running time was
only two minutes yes even God wants you
dead Ernest that'll teach you for saying
mello Yello is better than Mountain Dew
no need to thank me little lady
just a routine hero you know we're gonna
have a hard enough time stomaching
Varney's impressions kid I don't think
we need your help oh I see
I guess the stop button calls the
stagehand to push the prop out so after
that Ernest is assigned to clean out the
yard of a crazy old lady who I think
lives in the anus of the garbage master
from Fraggle Rock
nobody home my property Marty I've
transformed myself into a withering
black lady ma'am I'm just here to pick
up all this garbage got no garbage here
actually that's Eartha Kitt and she
doesn't seem very happy to see Ernest on
her property
you will bring down the curtain asshole
woe to you will you see the water get
out of here and don't come back
that was Catwoman everybody adolescence
around the world used to jerk off to
that pretty scary screen huh my heart
was in my throat
yeah rare gift wait why was she
screaming again that makes no sense
let's look at a script just says here
poorly done transition PS I wish that
Santa guy was in this one so like kids
of the neighborhood are putting together
a haunted house or rather a haunted box
but the evil bullies come to mess up
their fun you made a big mistake I'll
show you by running away some more so
they tilt earnest about their bully
problem to see if there's anything he
can do to help you need to learn it a
self defense lesson from tiny Botswana
that plucky little nation that defeated
that yeah I have Ottoman Empire it was a
dark night in the levites wanna yeah
that mullah flies boom uh no sorry
cinema snob already reviewed Caligula
and besides I don't want to see you
naked Wow where are they
and you're not you're I'm scared you
know it's like one of those guys from an
amusement park that tries way too hard
to entertain the kids you know to the
point where they're terrified of him he
got a merit badge and wholesales
I don't even get it it's the kid waiting
patiently while he goes to change into
every costume what's the logic behind
this Roman bulimia linked me home Tweety
day no trading bottom on yes you have
costumes stop it now
go make a difference in somebody's life
way to go artist do you smell fish funny
it's not funny it's not funny it's not
funny it's not funny it's not funny so
they decide to relocate their haunted
house to a tree house and of course
knowing ernest he takes the only one
that happens to be the burial ground of
an evil satanic demonic being
really those are the effects we're gonna
be seeing throughout this movie see
we're finding images in a Count Chocula
commercial for a whole world of trees
and you had to pick this one be the
favored place see how did she go from
Catwoman to cat lady
oh the prototype for bulk and skull have
arrived but it's okay this time the kids
come prepared
so earnest talks with the Eartha Kitt
lady and for some stupid reason actually
tells him how to summon the troll why
would she tell him that he can only be
awakened on the night before Halloween
like tonight when a Worrell like you
places his hand on a tree like this and
says yeah I call thee forth Trent or so
this of course summons the troll named
Trent or
yeah that's not very impressive now
trogdor that would be awesome
so the troll comes to life and starts
turning the children into little wooden
dolls because that somehow gives him his
power
I'm Abed roll earnest of course seize
the troll and tries to get some help
nearby it's a solo mission in this movie
to eat the fucking camera earnest down
what happen is you know what time it is
maybe old lady hackmore was right maybe
it was a troll luckily I was there to
beat it within an inch of its face
Holdenville uh what's up with the sudden
handheld camera I feel like we're on an
episode of cops kids out there
trespassing on that old lady's well yeah
but what happened then and have you
realized there's no edits in the scene
we don't see anything else except for
the front door what could they only
afford one corner of the house to
filming good night earnest cops is
filmed on location with the men and
women of law enforcement
so the troll heads back to the tree so
that he can use the doll to somehow
bring the other trolls to life look at
him he looks like a caricature of Mickey
Rourke playing willow sure so while
earnest runs around acting like an idiot
big shock we see the chubby guy in his
old skinny brother from the other
Earnest movies make their cameos again
the only strange thing is that's not the
chubby brother where'd he go
they were usually the funniest part of
the film's now well who knows maybe this
guy's fire fella comes in here the other
day and he says to me well Truitt
brothers give me a good deal or outboard
motor and some taxidermy supplies and I
said there's a fat puppy hate fast cars
or maybe I'd rather be castrated than
listen to him anymore
so the kids talk about whether or not
it's possible that Ernest actually did
see a troll come on there's no such
thing as trolls but Ernest saw something
out at the tree and he's never lied to
us before yeah but he's also gotten a
million things wrong I don't know you're
not scared are you
it's been a while let's see jim Varney
and Eartha Kitt try to album luck each
other again
a tone
getting stronger he has one child
already hsipaw by now just the kids
listen to the last two lines isn't weird
to say that she looks like Chester a
bums grandmother hurry I'm a bi-racial
half feline cat prison how come I'm
Network surprised so earnest sets up a
trap for the troll before he drops the
two kids off at their home sleeve the
troll fighting to us hi my dad don't
know what to do but about the party you
stay here where did that come from
she never expressed any interest to him
before it just her came out of nowhere
in fact I don't even think that was in
the script I think she's just a horny
girl I mean look at the boys face
he's totally shocked when she doesn't he
didn't know it was coming uh just go it
at Austin will edit it out and post
Celeste the girl relaxes at home
dreaming of spontaneous boy sex she
can't help but feel a predictable
jump-scare is about to attack her
cha-cha-cha
gggg shot cha-cha-cha
Oh smell fees it's just you he's on the
bed he's on the bed he's on the bed he's
on the bed he's on the bed and then I
going to eat me
and he's not done with just her soon he
starts going after other children as
well so he runs away from the troll in
the hopes of giving him the slip
he's behind him he's behind him he's
behind him he's behind him he's behind
him he's behind him he's behind him
oh what a sure he's behind him after the
boy finally out runs him it looks like
Ernest might have finally caught the
troll in his trap so he goes to the
police to show them the evil nasty
dangerous troll
slowly
me
he's payment in the penguin that seems
really kinky that big hahaha several
arguments about it a mini blue actually
it's just two kids dressed as trolls a
fella
yeah didn't see that one coming did you
this finally pisses off his boss as he
fires him from his garbage truck job but
does that stop the annoyingly persistent
earnest I've never been a quitter
why well I've never known when to quit
just ask my fourth-grade teacher he
never knew when to quit
oh okay that's one funny scene so his
scared shitless action set is almost
complete and he tries to get rid of the
only person who apparently can stop it
good god he looks like the love child of
large margin Gimli how are we supposed
to be afraid of him so as waiter shot
drives the car are you really
questioning this Ernest has a fight
scene in the back and manages to toss
him off
yeah why doesn't he just put it in
reverse oh hey a smart moment those are
rare why is this thing so hard to stop I
mean in the opening he was caught by a
neck a fucking gnat and here eaten a
goddamn pickup truck can't stop him was
he bench pressing all those heroes he
was under that tree so he makes it back
to kids house as they come across the
page that says how to defeat the troll
could I use that a little earlier huh
you know for a woman who knows
everything about these monsters she sure
did overlook the page about how to stop
him what was the book just not sucking
her in did it lose its edge in the last
few pages Oh can't destroy the troll
with em ah something K yeah milk it so
obviously milk medic that's it I'll
finish Bulgarian army yet look you don't
have to be a wheel of fortune wizard to
figure this out it's fucking milk
all right so they make it to the school
where they think the troll is going to
get his last victim when this happens
this thing looks feeling I'm not gonna
wear don't you talk back to me now you
march right in there I hate you
well I'm not too fond of you either
mommy I'm sorry I love you I love you
too
bipolar the family seriously what was up
with that one minute episode of 7th
heaven what that wasn't unconditional
she hated the costume she hated the kid
they had to apologize to make it better
it was based entirely on conditions fuck
it let's move on earnest runs into the
Halloween pageant hoping to save the
kids from the trolls next attack scary
costume I know it here history pal your
illness
I'm ready for you let's see how you like
a little yeah yeah me yeah I bet you
thought I couldn't find any this time of
year yeah you know I'm just gonna spend
this part and we'll be looking at what
meac is a rare slightly antiquated
beverage generally produced in Bulgaria
which may or may not be fictional damn
it will be your fucking fictional
beverages water tinging than you are
so of course the MEAC doesn't work but
he scared away by the ice-cream why
because it's a lobbyist lay back rim
shot rim shot oh boy that's rim shot you
sure it wasn't just one of his petrified
leaving us or something so earnest is
out for revenge as the boy figures out
what everybody else has 20 minutes ago
mother scare milk that's it milk you may
think you're strong now
but I'm drinking my milk which will
allow me to grow strong bones clear skin
and of course make me totally invincible
to all satanic troll attacks
well milk
it keeps you safe from us again so the
people of the village all head out there
to stop the troll just as he puts the
final child in the tree where was I oh
yeah whoa ha ha ha ha
it's time for troll splish kebab so
earnest tries to squash the troll but
again it doesn't work to better wasn't a
fucking net in there but it doesn't
matter the other trolls are born and run
a rampage on the villagers
look out we're being attacked by Rob
Zombie's deviantART page
Worrell selects a ball and steps to the
line it looks like a tricky 17 split uh
people are probably dying Ernest could
you hurry up with your funny little
speech there so while being harassed by
rejecting Garbage Pail Kids a bunch of
the schoolchildren pop up with their
secret weapon Oh nothing's gonna work
better find out let's do a body good
boys I guess they were lactose
intolerant milk motherfucker so
unfortunately he teams up with Ernest
and his multiple personality disorder to
spread the milk on all the trolls
hairspray will pick anything you know we
could utilize our time a little better
if you did less mugging usual day intake
of calcium bitches so all the trolls are
destroyed except for Trent or who used
all his evil powers to grow oh three
inches taller bone too strong for that
not even milk can stop me now well
that's a villainous catchphrase you
don't hear very often
he said his acting was wooden so Ernest
is up against the troll himself as he
somehow figures out that the only way to
defeat him is unconditional love come on
little fella that's just silly
of course showing unconditional love to
kill your enemy that's the ultimate
weapon of destruction peace and love
what am I missing here so the children
return back to normal as they fly into
the arms of their parents
need to wear depends their madre or we
really just scared shitless even some
children that were taken years ago we're
released as well sister is that you my
sister my sister oh you'll have quite a
bit of adjusting to do your years of
absence will lead to much psychological
scarring but we'll talk about that later
welcome back what there's nothing in
that tree for me what about rim shot rim
shot will live and you know what we're
going we'll go from battle the drill
that we're going to be every run at home
well I'm glad you could sit through it
folks I know I couldn't have tell you
what
complimentary Milk Duds on me so let's
Ernest scared stupid and boy is it
stupid I mean even if you don't like the
other Ernest movies you can sense
there's a passion and energy to them
like the people were at least having fun
while making it sadly you don't get that
here everything seems forced tired and
even unpleasant it's definitely the
weakest of the films released in
theaters and apart from some of earth
the kids overacting it's pretty
forgettable jim Varney god bless and I'm
sure he's trying but he just needed
better direction it's that horrible
combination of boring and unpleasant in
fact earnest care boring probably would
have been a more appropriate title but
what can you do
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and stay tuned
more nostalgia weaned is on the way
not even milk can stop me now